this is the world's best actor wrestler
this is the world's best wrestler turned
actor right here David Batista I saw a
knock at the cabin last week and I'm an
M Night Shyamalan fan I always have been
always will be his scary movies were
like the first movies I watched as a
child my comfort zone was in the alien
part of signs I love him so much and I
felt like knock at the cabin wasn't
scary but very enticing it left me
questioning my moral compass but what
stole the show truly what stole the show
is Dave Batista you guys I want to see
this man on stage if you love the
adrenaline rush of questioning your own
morals or if you just love Dave Batista
go watch knock at the cabin it's
genuinely very fun very eerie and the
best twist there is no twist